ihr kennt das man will einfach im
internet ein bisschen entspannen doch
dann gerät man in eine kommentarspalte
freunde der sonne herzlich willkommen zu
wie man bullshit erkennt teil 2 die
häufigsten scheinargumente diskussionen
können uns schnell triggern manchmal
sind es persönliche meinungen der pause
nicht zuständig ist ein monster manchmal
ist es die art der argumentation wo ist
hier die logik das macht doch keinen
sinn weiß wo das leben zu scheiden sie
halt die fresse woche haben wir über die
regeln für kritisches denken gesprochen
heute machen wir wenn man so will das
gegenteil nämlich die frage ist wie
sollte kritisches denken nicht aussehen
ihr lasst uns wieder inspirieren von 3 1
belohnt action die hohe kunst bullshit
zu erkennen aus karlshagen klassiker the
demon hunter worlds wallonie oder
bullshit beruht oft auf sein auge
menschen oder logik fallen die
kreissägen hier auflistet die liste ist
relativ lang aber trotzdem nicht wie
auch selbst hand vollständig es gibt
noch viel mehr aber deswegen möchte ich
auch selbst keinen anspruch auf
vollständigkeit hier erheben sondern in
diesem video
die acht häufigsten logik fallen hier
ausziehen die meiner meinung nach vor
allem im internet kommentarspalten zu
finden sind
ja und dann kann's losgehen nummer eins
die personen falle es sollte keinen
unterschied machen ob ein argument auf
einen neutralen blatt papier geschrieben
steht oder ob eine person dieses
argument vorträgt trotzdem neigen wir
dazu die person damit reinzuziehen
atomium kurz für argumente um atom ihnen
bezieht sich auf ein argument das ich
nicht auf den streitpunkt bezieht
sondern auf die person mit der ich
streite nehmen wir ein beispiel sagen
wir die diskussion geht um sexismus
dann sind beliebte art vornehmen
argumente zum beispiel sorry aber fanny
nazis kann ich nun mal nicht ernst
nehmen oder sorry aber als weißer
zizmann kannst du mal schön die klappe
halten
argumente über sexismus müssen auch
unabhängig von der person funktionieren
die diese argumente vor trägt auch ein
beliebtes argument wäre sowas hier du
brauchst mir gar nichts zu den risiken
von alkohol erzählen so viel wie du
sollst kein argument gegen alkohol
sollte unabhängig sein von der person
die dieses argument vorträgt wenn ihr
also das nächste mal in den kommentaren
persönlich angegriffen oder beleidigt
werden obwohl das überhaupt nichts mit
der diskussion zu tun hat dann verlegt
doch diese person einfach auf dieses
video auf genau diese stelle wo ich
jetzt sage hallo du siehst dieses video
gerade weil du ein atom einem argument
verwendet habe es sei natürlich der
charakter einer person oder die person
an sich hat etwas direkt mit der
streitfrage zu tun also auch atome nennt
muss man kritisch betrachten nummer zwei
die befangenheit fallen die meisten
menschen interessieren sich für
naturwissenschaften könnte ich glaube
wenn ich mir nur kommentare von mal der
durchlese aber dabei unterliege ich
einem so genannten observational
selection bayers sprich ich sehe nur das
was ich in meiner blase sehe und kann
das nicht zwingend auf die allgemeine
gültigkeit für den rest der welt
übertragen meisten menschen
interessieren sich für
naturwissenschaften die wahrheit freuen
und der sonne wir sind hier einfach nur
eine kleine versammlung von parsons
freaks mit betonung auf reach es nur
drei die ursachen falle wir sind immer
auf der suche nach begründungen nach
ursachen
doch dabei sind wir manchmal ein
bisschen voreilig es gibt zwei häufige
fallen erstens korrelation ist nicht
gleich kausalität zwischen
musikgeschmack und schulnoten besteht
hier nur eine korrelation also nur ein
zusammenhang nicht unbedingt eine
kausalität also eine ursache zweitens
die sogenannte cost hockey lobte hock
falle es passierte danach deswegen wurde
es auch dadurch verursacht ich habe
zuerst globally genommen und dann ging
meine kopfschmerzen dick deswegen habe
ich das auch den globuli zu verdienen
es ist eine mögliche begründung ja aber
das ist noch kein hinreichender beweis
ich kann jetzt also nicht die zeit
zurückdrehen keine globuli nehmen und
schauen wie meine kopfschmerzen dann
verlaufen werden nummer vier die kreis
falle sagt in ihren videos immer die
wahrheit
woher weißt du dass weil sie das in
ihren videos sagt erst rolle der sonne
ist so genannte circular reasoning eine
begründung die sich im kreis dreht ich
begründe eine behauptung mit der annahme
dass diese behauptung stimmt das feld
noch nicht mal so sehr auf wenn man für
die begründung die behauptung einfach
etwas umformuliert wie zum beispiel
spielen ein ehrlicher mensch weil ich
immer die wahrheit sage und niemals
lügen oder ich denke sehr
wissenschaftlich weil ich ein sehr gutes
kritisches denkvermögen habe ihr seht
was ich da mache ich gebe eine
begründung in dem ich weil sage aber was
da kommt es keine begründung sondern nur
meine ursprüngliche behauptung anders
formuliert und diese behauptung muss
erst mal überprüft werden nummer fünf
die beweis falle wenn ich jetzt behaupte
unser universum mit allem was es
beinhaltet ist nur ein winziger
bestandteil einer art elementarteilchen
eines gigantischen zwei phasen traf ich
nicht sagen und so lange mir niemand das
gegenteil beweist nämlich an das ist die
wahrheit nein
die beweislast liegt bei mir denn ich
eine behauptung aufstelle dann muss ich
auch beweisen dass wir teil eines
gigantischen zwei phasen sind solange
ich das nicht getan habe kann ich nicht
erwarten dass irgend jemand anderes
diese behauptung als wahrheit oder
mögliche wahrheit akzeptiert nummer
sechs die autorität fallen die argumente
eines professors oder einer
bundeskanzlerin oder einer chefin sind
nicht automatisch besser oder
glaubwürdiger als die argumente anderer
menschen autoritäten zuschreibt
kreissägen mit anführungsstrichen haben
in der vergangenheit fehler gemacht und
werden das auch in der zukunft tun in
der wissenschaft gäbe es gar keine
autoritäten sondern allenfalls und das
jetzt auch sehr wichtig expertisen
autorität sind zwei verschiedene sachen
die oft miteinander zusammenhängen aber
es ist ganz wichtig
kritisch hinzuschauen und zu
differenzieren ein doktortitel zum
beispiel wird verliehen für einfach
wissen weil sich jemanden jahre lagen
mit einem bestimmten thema auseinander
gesetzt hat dass er vor statt einen
doktortitel hat in unserer gesellschaft
aber auch etwas zu tun mit prestige oder
mit einem bestimmten status dass es
autorität das sollte bei einer
kritischen diskussion keine rolle
spielen die expertise die fachliche
allerdings schon am 7 die schwarzweiß
falle forstakademie heißt auf englisch
auf deutsch heißt es das falsche dilemma
das ist wenn ich nur zwei extreme als
möglichkeiten annehme und alles in der
mitte ignoriere entweder bist du vegan
oder du hast tiere entweder bist du
wissenschaftlerin oder du glaubst an
gott wenn wir in extremen denken nun
sachen in der mitte ignorieren ist doch
klar dass wir viel emotionaler
diskutieren nummer acht die strom
anfallen
germain als den englischen strohmann
gemeint ist vogelscheuche
das ist eine darstellung eines menschen
die aber vereinfacht und verzehrt ist
und genauso ist ein strohmann argument
die falsche darstellung eines
gegenargumente sin dem ich es
vereinfache oder verzerre
damit ich dieses gegenargument leichter
angreifen kann ich sag jetzt zum
beispiel unser kritisches denken wird
getrübt von unseren persönlichen
meinungen und erwartungen deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir unser kritisches denken
immer wieder selbst überprüfen wenn ich
daraus jetzt ein stromer machen wollte
würde ich sagen mai findet das andere
menschen zu blöd sind um logisch zu
denken was für seine argumente und logik
fallen kennt ihr noch und welche diese
acht ich jetzt vorgestellt habe findet
ihr am schwierigsten ich finde glaube
ich atom ihnen argumente besonders
schwierig für mich selbst und ich mehr
für das zum beispiel wenn ich mit der
rede von trump anschaue dann rat hat es
in meinem kopf geradezu vor lauter
terminen argumenten weil ich den man
halt nicht mag nicht ausstehen kann
aber da muss ich mich da auch selbst
erinnern wie das selbstbewusst werden
diese argumente beiseite stellen um mich
auf die sachlichen argumente
konzentrieren
ja die natürlich auch nicht viel besser
sind nur soviel jetzt erstmal zum
kritischen denken wie gesagt die liste
der logik fall ist eigentlich auch noch
länger und kreissägen ist auch nicht der
einzige große kritische denker das heißt
falls ihr euch interessiert für dieses
thema und sagt in zukunft würdet ihr
gerne noch mehr dazu wissen dann lasst
es mich wissen dann kann ich auch noch
mehr videos dazu machen wir sehen uns
jetzt erstmal nächste woche nächsten
donnerstag bis dahin plötzlicher